this is a production of cornell
university
thank you very much for the introduction
dr korsovich
and i want to say good afternoon to
everyone
and i want to thank the
yes i want to thank the plant breeding
and genetics
seminar committee and the chairman for
this opportunity
to present on the activities of the
innovation lab for
crop improvements
um here is a snippet of what i'm going
to talk about today i'm going to give us
a brief
background of myself and i'll go ahead
and introduce you all to the innovation
lab for crop improvement
and i'm gonna round up by talking about
our
centers of innovation which i believe is
the heartbeat of elc
so for those of you who do not know me i
am
originally from nigeria just like i was
introduced by dr krusevich
and um my first introduction to plant
science
research was through iid
so um that was where i received uh
inspiration actually to pursue a career
in plant research
prior to that encounter my family
routinely processed cassava
to make gary ourselves just for personal
consumption
not to take it to the market or any
anything like that so
the men would have his cassava and the
women were tasked to turn the cassava
into gary
and we would peel and process into gary
and that was short-lived because of
the death in the family you know as a
breadwinner
died and then life especially feeding
for
you know i have i was just like never uh
seven year old
feeding became very difficult you know
and a child what does a child know
rather than to eat breakfast lunch and
dinner
and there was a point in my life where i
witnessed poverty
you know firsthand and experienced food
insecurity and of course
all the while i craved i desired
to find a solution to these problems
because children
shouldn't have to worry about you know
where the next meal is going to come
from and not knowing
you know i would end up working in crop
improvement research
and cassava for that matter
so after this encounter i was privileged
to serve
a gay united that i was able to do for a
year and i worked with uh itabow tech at
that time
and it's now called the i.t about
science center
after which i was inspired to continue
plant research to obtain a master's in
crop protection and pursued
my phd in germany i did like the
molecular biology work at the max punk
institute for pampering research and i
had
the cassava transformation work um at
see it and
uh the the theme was uh proof of concept
that genes from arabidopsis italiana can
regulate flowering in cassava
because as we all know cassava is
recalcitrant of flowering
and flowers are very important for
breeders
so um this this research was so
interesting that we had flowers we have
cassava
in vitro plants flowering cassava
flowering in vitro so we were able to
prove that the ft over expression
uh increases the prolificacy of
flowering
production and extends the longevity of
flower development and i also
characterized the component
of the circadian clock upstream of the
ft
in cassava so after i obtained
my phd from the university of cologne
um i tried to secure a position
in the african continent and that was
kind of
a struggle but by divine providence i
found my way to the u.s
and i came to texas where i began my
immigration journey
and that is where i studied the
mechanisms by which legume plants
in in this case my chicago truncatula
control symbiotic
nitrogen fixation occurring nitrogen
without the use of energetically and
monetarily expensive and polluting
synthetic nitrogen fertilizers
so um typically we would
search for mutant lines in
or our robert's noble foundation is
close by
and then the mutant we found showed
nitrogen deficiency syndrome
symptoms rather the mutant fails to form
pink nitrogen fixing nodules that occur
in the wild type
symbiosis but instead it develops small
bomb
like noodles on its roots that are
blocked
at an early stage of development and
later off and has a lateral root
uh defect the functional nip
like d gene was cloned and shown to
encode a protein
in the broad substrate nitrate reductase
uh transporter family and the
nip lady lateral root deficient
transporter is essential for nutrition
and appropriate
and appropriate root architecture
so here is um some of the publications
and um after that experience i came to
to cornell where i walked out with team
setter
and um i continued you know came back to
working with cassava
after that detour um uh on over
expressing
uh redux's ft that elicits
extremely early flowering indicating
that cassava has
the necessary signaling components to
interact
with and respond to the ft gene product
so um my work was to advance
my work was to advance our understanding
of the molecular and physiological basis
of flowering in cassava
under different environmental conditions
where i investigated the expression of
cassava ft like
genes we characterized the
phosphatidyl ethanol amine binding
protein
family of genes it happens that in
cassava we have 10 of them
and we identified like a putative ft
like homolog ft like is like
um in arabidopsis it's the rate limiting
um gene that is responsible
for switching from vegetative to
reproductive production
implants and we compare the expression
of this homologues in various tissues
and uh we illustrated illustrated the
expression of this
homologues in various experimentally
controlled for the period and
temperature environment
in relation to the effects on cassava
regulation
another important roles in cassava so we
were able to advance the potential for
applications
in breeding program ultimately we found
out that i mean some of your sessions
that we used um the cassava is a long
day
flowers in if flowers early
under a long day for the period and
if you put them in shorty the flower
late
so um when i rounded up my um research
my postdoctoral experience i i was
serving on the board of the cornell best
program and best used to be called
broadening experiences in scientific
training and it's now known as um
careers beyond academia
it's a platform where phd students and
postdocs can
like find a fulfilling career outside of
academy it's more like your test driving
you know different career options so
even those
who pursue academic careers will need to
develop skills beyond the technical or
research skills
they are developing in their current
programs so best
provides opportunities for increasing
awareness
of the broad range of careers that exist
and examples are like in policy making
governance risk and compliance
industry entrepreneurship and management
communication
and research administration so um when i
now found myself
in the office of the vice provost for
research and the office of advice pools
for academic
integration it was excitingly different
environment for me where i learned more
about administrative research
administration
cornell leadership compliance issues the
office of the sponsor programs orion
worked on special projects i worked with
our research division communications and
ctl later i administered a startup
incubator for
commercialization of cornell technology
ventures in engineering
digital and physical sciences called
practice center just like uh
dr kressovich uh mentioned
where i manage the diverse
administrative functions of six
independent
venture teams with up to 50 individual
client
team members rested in the center
for those of us who don't know proxy
center it's like a sister center to the
kevin mcgovern center
which is a startup incubator for
commercialization of cornell life
sciences technology
so at that point when this current
position came up
i became excited and ready to take on
this challenge i'm
inspired really by the potential impact
that this work that the innovation lab
is
doing could have not only on the african
continent
but also on millions of people around
the globe
so i thought that this is a perfect
opportunity for me to fulfill like
that that desire and um
i found myself having a career
trajectory that starts with research and
continues with a large
ag research grant management
so that brings me to
elc excuse me
so um talking about innovation life for
crop improvement we cannot talk about
innovation
for company permit without talking about
the fit the future
and the global food food security
um so the future is a
us government initiative to sustainably
reduce
global hunger malnutrition and poverty
through agriculture led
economic growth to strengthen resilience
and improve human nutrition
this is led by um the usaid
um it was a a global food security act
and then it's implemented by uh the
global food security strategy
and these are the us partners that are
involved
uh the u.s government agencies and
departments are involved in
this research and the feed the future
has a 12
target um target countries
so um the implementing the implementing
partners
are important and these implementing
partners are
research funding organizations their
innovators and their
development partners
i would say that um we're about 21 for
the future innovation labs
that ranges on topics
about animal science research
to uh policy food policy and
um to plan research and the eoc
was um previously there are innovation
labs
that specifically deal a work on
specific crops but the eoc
is um working on a
broad range of crop with a global impact
and
this was awarded it was a competition
and um cornell
was awarded we are excited that cornell
was awarded it's a five-year effective
uh
last year and the award amount is
between five million and to develop
a crop improvement portfolio for
daenerys
so what is our mission our mission is to
partner
with national programs to identify help
them identify
develop pilot and transfer appropriate
tools technologies
and methods to equip them so they can
deliver
increased genetic gain for for better
seats
into the market for small older farmers
so we ultimately reduce um
malnutrition and hunger our approach
so historically donald organizations
um will provide funding for
research but the they drive the goals
and priorities for research but in illc
we we have this approach of um
bottoms bottoms up approach where the
ilc dr
the sorry daenerys the drive the goals
and priorities for research
why because we believe that sustainable
solutions will have a long-term effect
if the um if daenerys specifically
identify their unique needs
you know and target innovations or
design innovations to solve them
so and um we focus on providing
you know resources in terms of
cutting-edge science
and collaboration and all that they need
that we believe that will help them
to succeed
so what is our tactic um our tactics
um is include this core
interdisciplinary team of scientists
that focus
on party setting you know of breeding
interventions that will increase the
responsiveness of this interventions and
potentially improve
uptake of new varieties we have a trade
discovery
team genomics phenomics brilliant
informatics and instrumental capacity
evaluation
that we believe are the core
um excuse me
core research areas we call them area of
inquiry
that are essential for success in
daenerys and here is like a sketch that
talks about the area of inquiry
deploying tools technology
methods through a breeding pipeline for
a healthy crop improvement system
and i'll take you uh quickly through the
management team
we have dr christopher harley as our
associate director
and monifa as a program assistant and we
also have
the team of um communications support
and administrative
and event um personnel
just a brief uh uh going through the air
of inquiry
team leads the faces behind tactics
these are these are um our
core core uh era of inquiry team
and uh we have uh jeff morris from
colorado state so we have jessie poland
from kansas state we have um
deal tavaraja from clemson university
that works on phenomx and the rest of
our team are all cornell
cornell beast we also have a
cross-cutting theme
we believe that um we have a
cross-cutting thing lead just
designated leading in elizabeth and we
have d
and margaret also working together and
the cross-cutting theme
is very important in that is about
increasing awareness and understanding
of the importance of addressing and
incorporating addressing and
incorporating
gender youth nutrition and resilience
and crop improvements
i want to i like two things that the
cross cut cutting
theme team have done um so far
and that is um training and translation
training due to kobe they were just
talking about cover 19 it has been
difficult to travel in person
and with the rising numbers of infected
uh cases travel restrictions were
probably not easy so
our cross-cutting theme they have
designed outline
and online excuse me sensitization
training to reach
our cois more quickly than would have
been
in person so that work could continue
just by the travel restrictions and i
think that this is a
very great idea that they have initiated
two trainees already in
gender and youth to serve as a framework
for additional
two trainings in nutrition and
resilience and
the trainings will also serve as a
public tools
accessible by any way as well as
templates for the other area of
encourage
whom we wish to pursue the same for
their own
area of expertise
so the other
accomplishment that they have you know
done is that we know that all the
centers of innovation i'm going to talk
about later
they are awarded in countries that are
primarily non-english speaking
or they speak english as part of its
colonial heritage
and we have um
we have stated that the objective of uh
the eoc
includes diversity and inclusion and we
have reinforced those through our
strategic management and prioritization
of cross-cutting themes throughout the
project
so they are working to formalize access
in fact
amazon say also that um
i just read an email that was sent to
one of our cois in senegal
in french and i'm impressed that
you know we are working so much to make
sure that
uc succeeds and if that means that we
want to translate
you know the work to remove
any communication gaps and you know so
they're working to formalize access to
translation and
or interpretation services to support
inclusive
outreach and capacity building for the
cross-cutting theme
as well as the eoc team and initiative
all right and then i'll just go through
um our
advisory committee our advisory
committee uh as
they are seasoned professionals with
international experience
in leading research and development in
the private sector
one of them is linked with a private
sector in asia
and together we believe that our core
team irreverent curry leads
and a cross-cutting theme together with
the management entity will leverage its
connections to engage
efforts that connect with private sector
priorities
so we can ensure technology and method
advancements and transfer them to
advance our married partners
now it takes me to our tiger crops our
target crops are root tubers and bananas
legumes
excluding um soybean and peanut we have
minutes
and sargon and i would also talk about
the quick wings who are the quick things
the quick wings were
um were identified as short-term
projects
with a moderate investment and for a
long-term impact are we identified at
the time that the proposal was submitted
and we have quick win partners in um
in uganda we have two in uganda we have
uh
one in 80 we have one in nepal and one
in
in senegal
so a quick queen in uganda one of the
quick wins in uganda is um
working on vivo resistant sweet potato
a quick queen and other quick winning
uganda is working on fast cooking
iron and zinc buffer five being using
genomic selection pipelines and our
nipple quick queen is working on
high protein quality uh lentils using
non-destructive you know
typing tool and our quick win in senegal
is working on staggering and drought
resistant
chrome millet using quantitative traits
um using by cross nested associated
mapping excuse me
and our quick win in aiding
is working to increase the rate of
genetic gain in low budget
developing countries some breeding
program using
um genomic assisted selection
so um i would share some of is the
progress she has made so far
and his forward product for profile is
sugarcane effect resistant
multipurpose sorghum
he works on a point
proof of concept proof of concept to
demonstrate the possibility
of enhancing genetic gains in sargon
with rapid
cycling genomic selection excuse me so
it has
several genomic cycles or from sugar
cane if it resists that multipurpose
sorghum with broad adaptation to
tropical growth environments those were
completed
and then we went to genomic cycle
selection theory machine
selected families with yields exceeding
the yield of the
phenotypic recurrent selection and um
the best breeds from this genomic
selection cycles and phenotypic
recurrent selection cycle are currently
on their multilocation trials and then
we can see that
um the genetic genomic selection cycle
three
which is under a lot of stress water
stress and severe effect infestation
um yielded you know it had
increased in green yield and
um it's going to continue um some work
to validate new varieties and
participatory trials it's going to
validate id types and
evaluate new training set
for more locations
and i'm going to talk about our centers
of innovation and it's the i believe
they are the heartbeat of um
of the uc
so first of all to identify uh
the centers of innovation we requested
for an application because our goal is
to build the top tier scalable building
programs and co-create a toolbox
package covering all the six areas of
inquiry
and we are we had a goal to select
one nari in each region
the east african region the west african
region and the southeast asia region and
the latin
american caribbean region
and then the
the requirement was that they
write a proposal
for projects for three years
and define clearly the product profiles
for tiger crops
the rfa will impact it must be led by
narys
in defeated future countries and they
should articulate
the development goal and clearly
indicate how becoming a ceo will
increase benefits for women
youth climate resilience and nutrition
still on the global food security
strategy
three objectives um and the budget is a
maximum
of a million and um entity start date
was october
first of this year priority was given to
institutions that have
linkages with the us minority serving
institution
the minority group of women and early
career scientists
and also essential that they partner
with nuri's
universities and institutions and cgr
centers and proposals should be
submitted
well an advantage is if it's submitted
by inter interdisciplinary groups of pi
and they should include capacity
building plans that is articulated at
the individual and institutional level
and then their product profiles should
address gender
and youth-based constraint and they
should show potential
for all these three global food security
strategy objectives
so the rfa process the rfa process
was started by um
the reading questions and webinars so
for the webinar we had about
150 registrants from 41 countries
and um the letters of intent
uh it's the letters of intent uh were
submitted by
a hundred and four applicants
across 26 countries
and we filtered those 104 applications
to about
40 using different criteria if they
they followed if you were doing a
research in the mandate crop
or have mary p.i or the country is
eligible
another supporting document 1012 was
shortlisted during the
the co-creation uh phase
we um we merged
out of those shortlisted candidates we
merged
two of um the projects together
and then there was like a matrix of
calls with the area of inquiry
and cross-cutting themes team leaders
to make sure that they prepared a
proposal
to um reflect
all the priorities of evc in the areas
of inquiry and the cross-cutting team
and then we had ten final proposal that
was submitted
and four and four was friday
these four are um costa rica
this are the ones that emerged
and the one from senegal
and uganda and malawi we have already
worked with 80
in senegal so
um it's really exciting to
um work or have
you know footprints in the global
spectrum and uh
we are also um working to
include you know in
um work in in asia
so the centers are the central america
and caribbean crop improvement alliance
casia the center for of innovation for
crop improvement
for east and southern africa ccsa is
in malawi in uh with
michael japan and the east african
center of innovation for finger murder
and slogan
in person of uh scorpio at the king
that uh there's national seminary
resources
research institute in canada and we have
crop improvement innovation in west
africa
and that's a personal key
so um the central america the casia is
led by
jose and gail and
nari is institut instituto national the
innovation in transparency and
technology at
gopicaria inter and cascaya university
and their crops
are common beans soccer and sweet potato
so they have um the year they're set out
to to work on
the year plan is uh they want to
validate product profiles in coastal
curricula in
80 and they want to test uniform
regional nurseries using participatory
approaches
and expand the sagam rapid recurrent
and genomic selection approaches both in
costa rica and 80 because um
gael is already working on sargon
and also they want to incorporate
physiological breeding
and with the the beans the crop
they want to begin the magic population
development
and for their sweet potato they will
work on
rapid recurrence selection and
physiological breathing
and the the other
the second center of innovation i'm
going to talk about is the east african
center of innovation for finger
millet and socom this the lead country
is uh
it's uganda and we have partner
countries and cairo and
atari and um excuse me
and the crops are going to work on these
soccer man finger millet
and uh this coffee the plan that jovia
asked for
this year is that she wants to conduct
her finger millet and sodom
value chain and do like a market
analysis
to document the drivers for adoption of
technologies
so and then she wants to identify
sources of resistance to some stresses
and also nutritional quality
sources she wants to um
do regime and molecular market discovery
for normal traits
and develop and optimize tools and
methods for efficient
phenotyping and rapid regeneration
regeneration and advancement of
desirable traits
and digitized virgin programs for
targeted breeding
in east east africa
and this work is is very
very important because we know that
having the right
tools technologies and methods they will
be able to execute this and she also
wants to um
build like an irrigation system because
i understand that um
it's a semi-arid area so they lack
this drought so to have
more to expand the nurseries they need
to be able to keep the plants alive
so and they need water so these are one
of the major investments
that we are going to um be making
and the next uh uh center of innovation
is the crop innovation in west africa
see why it's led by guido
and um the pi kopi
is uh mermaid and uh we have affiliated
um
countries in burkina faso in era and uh
in brad
immediate and the crops they're working
on is um
pramilit sorghum and kerby the work they
have
set up to um do in in year one is to
update their existing
reading product profiles to seek
to understand adoption differences
and improve like accept market access
accessibility
uh for the sogom the permanent and
copy and you want to implement more than
ttms for arabic discovery and validation
of
traits for genetic gain and product
concept
development and also it wants to use
some genomic selection and
whole genome prediction of carb breeding
values using simulation
and gs pipelines for optimizing the west
african reading programs
and it's going to do this using uh
modernized phenotyping and data capture
platforms
of breeding pipelines and ultimately
digitize breeding activities
and fair data and that face the capacity
of computational systems to assess
to find access interoperability and
reuse data
and now the last
center is the center of innovation for
crop improvement
for east and southern africa and is led
by
michael chipetter who is the principal
investigator and
and jessica is a cool is a copyi
in malawi and the partner countries
are mozambique and tanzania
and they are located in longwoo
university of agriculture and natural
resources
and they're working on happy
so is um here one plan
is uh to conduct genetic gender
sensitive healthy value chain analysis
and that is um more of designing like
study tools and framework
for comprehensive gender sensitive copy
value chain
analysis using questionnaires and
checklists
and conduct trade preference uh
surveys and is going to characterize
phenotypic and genomic diversity calpe
gem plasm you know
um phenotype selective geoplasm or
britain lines
and collect for key traits in multiple
sites
and it's going to genotype some of the
calcium geoplasm
and we sequence copy from the lines
and just like some nutrition variety
profiling and
under developing and selecting more
productive and nutritious copy lines
they will
it's basically selecting like the best
parental lines for generating
crosses and i included copper's
development here
as an important um
an important part of
our work in in uc
it's important that the develop capacity
so that they can
self sustain and they're going to train
on deployment and implementation of
ems in malawi you want to train on
gender responsive breeding
and training genomics enabled breeding
and informatics it's it's clear that
they lack all these tools so
these are some of the targets and you
want to ultimately train
post-graduate students and project
personnel who can
continue to
[Music]
work in this three countries
so if they have this capacity
institutional
development they can
you know be self-reliant or to continue
to sustain themselves so
um that's i think that's very very
important
um part of their
year one plans and with that
i have come to the end of my of my
talk and i'm excited that um we are
working on these
different regions because i believe
that uc is strategically positioned
to deploy crop improvement research to
the narys
and one of the take-homes
is that nari is our brand we are working
for the narratives
so that they can be self-reliant they
can
self-sustain they can breed their own
crops just so that they can
um eliminate
food insecurity and i believe that our
cows and quick win research
will ancillary breeding locally and
originally adapted crop varieties
that target small older farmers and
other seeds systems related outreach
so that their work and their product can
be received
by the end users and
families and people that need the seats
and ultimately
of course that's the ultimate goal to
advance
and fulfill the three um global food
security
strategy which is economic growth
resilience and human nutrition with this
i'd like to thank our partners
um from kansas state clemson
and i'll see you guys and i've come to
the end of my talk
thank you
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu